these are soldiers from mozambique and
rwanda
in the port city of mussim word darpraya
the region in northern mozambique's cabo
delgado province
was the last stronghold of an armed
group locally known as al-shabab
the fighters had used it to launch
attacks across the province
since 2017. more than 2 thousand people
have been killed
and hundreds of thousands displaced the
soldiers here are upbeat
their commanders say it will now take
less than a month to complete the
offensive in the entire province
the enemy hubba was this mussina de
prior
and as you have seen along the way
most of the enemy are killed
were killed along the way so others
have disappeared in a forest we are now
planning to pursue those few enemy
pockets
along our axis
mozambique has been struggling to fight
against the armed group
which is believed to have ties with isil
the town of palma 80 kilometers away
is a scene of the most recent major
attack fighters laid siege for days in
march
killing several people and causing many
to flee from their homes
it was one of several attacks that was
planned for muslim water prior
so the town falling back into the hands
of government forces
is a strategic victory rwanda deployed
its troops in july
to help mozambique's national army the
enemy was estimated to be between
2000 and 3000
but it was deployed in its moral groups
so concerning
the importance of the ground it is very
important because it is helicopter over
the
terrorists many people are still afraid
to go home
and continue to live rough in camps for
the displaced
we did not cause the conflict we are
suffering losses without knowing the
cause
we are just ordinary citizens
mozambicans in this region rich in oil
gas and other minerals say they want
peace they want to rebuild their towns
and they hope the troops will keep them
safe enough
to go back home catherine soy al jazeera